[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 le débat
il sera question de transport cette
semaine plus particulièrement d'éco
mobilité crise de l'énergie
réchauffement climatique il a fallu
faire évoluer nos modes de déplacement
les rendre plus sûrs plus sobre mais
aussi réaliser et donc et ses
aménagements qui sont adéquates les
pouvoirs publics ont donc un rôle
essentiel à jouer au niveau national
mais aussi local à saint quentin en
yvelines quelle est la politique menée
est ce suffisant pour en parler on
débattre en plateau véronique côté
millard vice-président de mobilité et
transport à saint quentin en yvelines et
olivier paréja conseiller communautaire
d'opposition europe écologie à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines également
bonsoir à tous les deux on va tout
d'abord commencé par un exemple concret
vers unique au quai côté millard il ya
ce projet autolib sur l'agglomération ça
c'est un exemple concret un peu
d'écomobilité ce sont ces automobiles
électriques partager ce sera lancé en
2010 est même si le projet a pris un peu
de retard c'est sûr là le projet a pris
un petit peu de retard nous sommes en
négociation avec avec bolloré et le
syndicat puisque bolloré est en train de
revoir sa politique de 2
d'autolib sur sur ces différents
territoires autour de paris donc voilà
nous sommes en pourparler il ya des
réunions d une réunion technique qui va
être organisé très prochainement et on
espère que d'ici 2017 les autolib soient
installés sur le territoire de saint
quentin certains même été un petit peu
rapide comme la commune de guyancourt
qui allège je crois déjà installé une
certaine certaines installations
électriques donc qui sont vraiment dans
les starting blocks pour accueillir ses
voitures ses stations ça veut dire la
mobilité durable cet éco mobilité vous
la prenez en compte dans la politique du
tout puisque on rentre enfin fonction du
nombre d'habitants un certain nombre de
stations une station faisant six
véhicules et c'est donc cette le projet
ne coûtera pas directement d'argent
commune puisque c'est sky qui va prendre
donc un emprunt qui sera remboursé avec
ce que va reverser les communes au
niveau d'occupation du domaine public
j'ai par ailleurs c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle
les idées portées notamment par europe
écologie pendant des années sont rentrés
dans les moeurs aujourd'hui je sais pas
si europe écologie peut réclamer
l'exclusivité des idées écologistes mais
c'est sûr que l'autopartage le fait
d'imaginer que les gens vont pas
nécessairement tous avoir deux trois
voitures par foyer par exemple c'est
nécessairement quelque chose d'assez
positif après sur sur le modèle autolib
on peut se poser des questions c'est
c'est quelque chose qui coûte énormément
à la collectivité même si après on peut
sous forme de deux prêts atténuer
l'effet mai mais quelque part ça va
coûter 90 mille euros par station et on
peut il existe des modèles alternatifs
qui sont peut-être moins moins coûteux
pour la collectivité le fait de faire
appel à bolloré n'est peut-être pas la
solution la plus avantageuse mais on va
pas non plus noircir est ce qu'il
faudrait c'est qu'en complément de cette
façon de partager l'automobile donc qui
est qui et qui est autolib qui est un
système fermé on puisse imaginer que
l'agglomération développe aussi tous les
systèmes d'autopartage comme comme le
covoiturage on voit dans l'est dans les
communes avoisinantes de l'agglomération
le système pousse yvelines qui permet de
faire de l'auto stop un tout petit peu
organisés donc qu'ils aient quelque
chose aussi qui est très intéressant
quillan eux pas grand chose un peu de
quelques autocollants des places de
stationnement de la signalétique de
l'animation de la part des collectivités
et qui peut aussi rendre service à la
fois l'utilisateur le conducteur qui
partage ses frais et pio ceux qui sont
transportés donc c'est aussi des
solutions comme ça qu'il faut mettre en
plus du côté un petit peu un peu
clinquant ce2 en béton assez à saint
quentin en yvelines on pourrait en faire
plus c'est ce que ces solutions existent
moi je voudrais déjà dire autolib c'est
important que ce sont des véhicules
électriques et en matière de pollution
je pense que c'est important de
développer justement des véhicules
électriques mais vous avez parlé de
l'autopartage oui ça existe bien sûr le
covoiturage et existe avec le système il
faut que ces oiseaux aps vous avez
également parlé de possible in c'est un
dispositif on a rencontré le créateur de
ce dispositif récemment et dont combat
en certainement je pense de présenter
aux élus très prochainement parce que
c'est effectivement un dispositif
extrêmement intéressant après tout ça
s'inscrit aussi dans le plan de
restructuration du réseau de bus c'est à
dire limiter le nombre de véhicules qui
circulent et puis on les circulations
douces dont on aura peut-être l'occasion
d'en parler le plan d de la terre de
déplacement inter-entreprises haug
également enfin je trouve que pour être
une commune nouvellement arrivé dans
saint quentin en yvelines c'est
extraordinaire l'ensemble des
dispositifs pour les classes voilà qui
peut exister et qu'il est mis en place
qu'on va pouvoir élargir aux douze
communes etc aimerait vraiment avec
beaucoup d enthousiasme qu'on travaille
sur tous ces dispositifs sachez que je
suis très attaché à l'environnement est
très sensible tout les problèmes que
nous rencontrons et notamment à la
qualité de l'air et tout ce qui pourra
contribuer à l'améliorer nous y serons
très très attentif et très sociaux sur
la qualité de l'air je pense qu'il ya
une chose qui serait intéressante et je
l'avais dit au conseil communautaire à
l'occasion du festival it et c'est que
on n'a pas de capteur vers 5h le pca
était pc à venir donc le plan climat
énergie territorial
voilà donc qui est quelque chose que la
communauté d'agglo vient de lancer qui
est une obligation tout les toutes les
agglomérations
en france et donc qui va définir un peu
la politique
donc air climat
de la communauté d'agglomération donc
qui est quelque chose de très positif
puisque sa part par un diagnostic et
ensuite on verra les actions qu'on peut
mettre en oeuvre et donc à cette
occasion là j'avais signalé que air
parif n'a pas de capteur dont qui est
l'association qui permet de mesurer la
pollution n'a pas de capteur sur la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que le capteur
le plus près et dans la plaine de
versailles qui n'est pas du tout
enfin versailles plutôt la ville de
versailles d'heures que la plaine de
versailles et donc du coup ce serait
intéressant d'avoir plus d'informations
sur où on est ton haut niveau pollution
et
pour savoir ce qu'il faut faire et
comment si on met en oeuvre un certain
nombre de choses le le plan local de
déplacement inter communal auquel vous
faisait allusion prévoit de réduire de 3
% les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
liées liés à la mobilité d'ici 2020 bon
on pourra peut-être revenir sur
l'ambition de ce 3 % mai mais à un
moment il faudra qu'on ait aussi les
moyens de mesurer 2 sur place les faits
pour les habitants en particulier sur la
pollution de l'air et c'est quelque
chose de très important et je suis
désolé que le conseil départemental des
yvelines par exemple est décidé de
retirer sa subvention à airparif qui me
semble être un moyen de mesures
important pour pour déclencher des
actions au niveau des collectivités
territoriales pour avancer un tout petit
peu puisque vous avez parlé de ces
circulations douces on peut évoquer la
situation des vélos aussi des pistes
cyclables parce que la mobilité à vélo
c'est important néanmoins je vais juste
faire une toute petite parenthèse pour
préciser que sur le réseau bus et une
consultation qui est en cours en ce
moment que vous l'avez évoqué c'est ce
réseau de bus c'est jusqu'au 15 octobre
pour auprès de saint quentin en yvelines
vous exprimer sur les réseaux de bus qui
permettra d'adapter ensuite les
différentes les différentes lignes pour
revenir sur les circulations douces sur
la circulation à vélo aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il ya suffisamment piste cyclable à
ce qu'elles sont bien entretenues bien
aménagé à saint quentin en yvelines
alors il ya des pistes cyclables à saint
quentin en yvelines il ya un plan que
nécessairement pour utiliser le vélo
aller régulièrement au conseil
communautaire à bello et tous les jours
pratiquement pour aller au travail
ce l'infrastructure existe mais elle
nécessiterait d'être étendu certains
points noirs d'être traités et puis
surtout d'être rénovée car en
particulier sur la partie alors je
connais moins les clés
mais sur la partie
saint quentin en yvelines vers storim
cias
il ya énormément de rénovations à faire
et les investissements qui était prévu
au moment où on a lancé le pld dans la
même dans le même conseil communautaire
on a à la fois réduit le nombre de
kilomètres qu'on allait rénover sur les
pistes cyclables et en même temps
déployé tout un tas de l'objectif très
ambitieux sur le plan local de
déplacement donc il faut il faut qu'ils
ont face à un écart enfin qu'on n'est
pas d'écart entre les objectifs et les
faits par exemple si on prend la
rénovation du boulevard de kessel à
montigny c'est quand même dommage que
cette rénovation contrairement à ce que
prévoit la loi alors qu'ils qui indique
que quand on fait une rénovation de
urbaine à l'intérieur enfin d'une
chaussée à l'intérieur d'une ville on
est censé des limites et des transports
des couloirs pour les cyclistes ou des
aménagements pour les cyclistes et là
sur le boulevard de kessel par exemple
il y aura rien alors on doit les
cérémonies côté n'y a pas ce cas
beaucoup de points sont là c'est
l'entretien et puis peut-être sur le
point de la situation ces 195 km de
pistes cyclables parce que quand même
assez considérable 900 je crois à peu
près 900 places de stationnement pour
les vélos et 400000 déplacements par
jour donc en vélo donc beaucoup de gens
de personnes utilisent utilisent leur
vélo pour
ce que j'en sais le
ce territoire est assez bien couverts en
piste cyclable en stationnement de vélos
même s'il va y avoir d'ailleurs un
projet de vélo station pour réparer les
vélos sur la gare de saint-quentin même
pour louer des vélos à moyen et long
terme et c'est donc la politique de vélo
continue à se développer elle va se
développer avec les communes bien sûr
entre entre dans la dans
l'intercommunalité est également in au
budget entre 600 à 1 million d'euros
quand même par an pour la réalisation de
ces pistes cyclables récemment donc
cette année il ya eu donc l'avenue du 8
mai 1945 entre dont bouygues et la gare
qui a été réalisé on sait vous l'avais
dit à juste titre qui a encore des
manques je pense à magny les hameaux
mais nous ça nous avons des contraintes
parce qu'il s'agit aussi d'une
départementale dont nous travaillons
avec le conseil départemental et sur des
travaux qui n'ont pas pu être réalisés
parce que parfois il y avait des
contraintes très technique où les voies
sont pas là c'est l'âge où on est obligé
de couper des rangées d'arbres très
importante qui fait qu' on hésite un
petit peu enlevé la végétation et qui
sont pas toujours voilà facile à
réaliser quant à l'entretien parce que
vous en avez parlé effectivement il ya
une enveloppe budgétaire maintenant qui
a été missionné pour l'entretien de ces
pistes cyclables et des efforts
certainement un feria suivre donc
d'isoler les toiles de projet à bras le
corps peut-être une question que peuvent
se poser les saint quentinois un système
de vélib je peux exister sur 50 ans
arrivé alors pour le moment c'est pas
d'actualité parce que ils préfèrent il
semblerait que la demande se plus pour
des locations moyenne et longue durée
avec des vélos qu'on puisse ramener
d'ailleurs à son domicile donc c'est
plus une option qui a été choisie autant
on est en auto lit mais là c'est une
option qui a été choisie pour les vélos
pour le moment après tout et tout est
imaginable oui oui parce
qu'effectivement il ya je pense que le
rôle des collectivités c'est justement
d'essayer de susciter
de favoriser les déplacements et si on
prend le développent développement sur
l'agglomération de lille des vélos en
libre service vélib ça s'appelle paviani
balle il s'appelle je sais plus comment
ça a quand même fait augmenter de près
de 80% la pratique cycliste sur la ville
donc c'est absolument énorme aujourd'hui
les déplacements à vélo il y en a
peut-être beaucoup mais ça reste quand
même très très marginal c'est de l'ordre
de 2 % savent sur l' enquête sur la
dernière enquête des déplacements sur
saint quentin donc quand on voit des
villes des villes du nord au danemark en
hollande ou même en allemagne où on est
plutôt dans des 23 pour cent on se dit
que là la collectivité a un énorme rôle
pour favoriser aider alors ça peut être
des vélib ça peut être des aménagements
vous avez parlé du pôle gare et de la
station effectivement casillas est un
énorme souci le fait que que des gens se
fassent voler leurs vélos à la gare
aujourd'hui ou ne puissent pas se le
faire réparer sa séquelle c'est un
projet qui est important on va s'arrêter
là puisque cette émission touche déjà à
sa fin cette discussion qu'on a pu avoir
autour d'écomobilité juste pour conclure
chacun je voudrais juste vous entendre
sur cette problématique que rencontrent
aussi les saint quentinois parce qu'on
parle d'écomobilité d'environnement tout
cela c'est très bien mais la réalité le
matin ou même le soir pour rentrer dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin autour
de la nationale 10 par exemple ce sont
les bouchons le quotidien des
automobilistes par exemple il ya des
pistes des solutions qui sont envisagées
les trains les trains améliorer
améliorer les trains la tangentielle
ouest la ligne 18 améliorer aussi les
airs vers les reverser le rer b les
lignes les lignes de train je pense que
déjà ça ça facilitera énormément les
choses et les rabattage aussi dans les
gares par des transports en commun pour
éviter justement encore de prendre son
véhicule personnel donc il ya des choses
à faire et ce qui est un consensus
autour de ça quelle que soit la couleur
politique des élus les choses à dire que
je peux que des vies mais par contre
faut aller jusqu'au bout je rappellerai
par exemple que la départementale 30 là
qui va vers plaisir et ont complètement
en train d'être refaite et il n'y a pas
de couloir pour les bus c'est quand même
dommage quand on refait de façon
importante alors c'est peut être
partagée entre le département mais si la
ville agglo la ville de plaisir avait
poussé on aurait peut-être eu là une
façon de aussi de construire
l'agglomération de relier ce sera
l'objet d'un autre débat spécifiquement
sur cette rd 30 et en plus le chantier
grand d'être terminée on aura l'occasion
d'en parler merci à tous les deux d'être
venu sela 6 7 8 le débat qui portait sur
la mobilité durable l'éco mobilité à
saint quentin mardi 18 octobre nous nous
pencherons sur la sélection à
l'université nos émissions sont à revoir
en replay sur notre site internet
[Musique]